.
>> TO A
T VICE PRESI WAS ASK ABOUT ORAL.
SHE  MANCHINESENSATCT  NE THAT
ESIGHTLYD SEEMED TO
ep Y ENDED BY IT.D O?
DE,  LEASTA
WHESHWAT THE LAD SO WIT
TOR WHO ENOLT OF THEDEEN CAPITO.
SOETT LIST
TALKE ABOUIT
>>E RENT O COUNTRYN ?
E ONCHARLEMAGNE, NO,, IT'SID
A REPUBLIN ABOUT AST.EN.
>>K JOE MANCHIN IS A
IS JOE BIDEN, AND I'M VIC
PRESIDENT, AND MY NAMES KAMALA
HARRIS.
epRESTING 'S BETWEEN THESE.
HE'S TIC, AND 'T
SEEN I
THERE'T OFTION, ASYOOW,  AROUND
BACK BET
THAT JT ONE IT.
BOE N CAPITOMANCHEN,
>> KAMALA HARRIS WAS VERY TE
CA FE.
JO VERY MUCH
FOMORE HEAEN
ADNINTEXTENDS THE NER PLAN.
THERE WAS AN INTENSE LUNCH THAT
LEFT SOME WITH A SER CASOF
HEARTBURN.
FEELG?TED, DISAPPOINTED.
>> ReporteT OINTS IT
>> YOU HAVE RS, JUST SAH CHLOT.
EVERNG PEOPLE IN COUNTRY
SHOULD KNOW THAT A 50-50 SENAT
SUCKS, A WE CAN'T T
ID BY THAST
THERE FROM HAWAII.
ATF THINGSRIE.
I ST FSHOULD TAKEWHS TONTIONINGS
SA
I SAAT, TOE
EX.Y RIDINGN
HEE Y ISE
WE ARE RIGHT N
THE LASTEAJO HE
HA BACT SLAMMI.
SIS ARE T.
ORUBTINGINKIE TO
PEOPLE IN R  YOU ONES G.YOAR JU
THAT WOULD BE THE REPUBL  AT TH.
THAT'S GD OR ME TO THE DIAGU
E DOZENSOTPRESSION BILLSL
EV SPEAK, JIM, S O OT PROTECTIO.
>> LETNATOILS FROMINIA
IME HERE.
LET'S WATCH.
Rte PRESSURING
TO CHANGE THE TIO ONE PRRE
>> Reporter: ARE YOU G TCH
A  EXTENSION --  TOTHEPOWE TIMED
TRY TO G THOR
TWO OR A FEW A
SOY WOMEN
TWOE E CHILD S NOT
THAT, CHILD CARE CEN PRESCPT COE
THOSE  T
R, AND SO L OF THE PROE
IMPORTANT.
I' STAND HE AND TAT BREAKINGTER.
LAST I
T WHERE JOIDTH THE
KI- BASS
WANTED TO ASK YUTSOMETHING  K
ING EL
HE HAI INTERESTING T
I THIN TEAVO, WE'RE ALGOING A  T
THAT WHEM PUHAK
THOSRAS?
DEPENDICH ISSTBL
LIUS O FAIR ELECTION. BEFORE,UR.
THMAT THAT MUCH
HARDER FOR PEOMO O OF SUPPREWA.M
TR
O SORT
THEIR, LIKE, HEY, WE'RGOING TO
UGR YOU TO VOTE.LUCK
O BE THEIR>>GSION.
WHAT IS GOING TO GETVO RE
THINY HOPE D HAVE A
CAT FO
AIKTHAT AREA?RE'S ANY HOPE ATO
FIBULLE TOS TIE DON'T DO
VOE  VER
?
SO CONES>> DU STIC?WEN A TH
CHANGE THAT WOUSO SUPPORT VOTER
LEGISLATION.
KEPA IE -- R, WHOO T WANTION
ION WILL
THE AMANPLT TO
I WOULD LOVEICANS DOATEAE OU TO
CE THE AMECA
>> IE HEG NS OF ANOT
HA